world of warcraft has been around for
nearly
16 years and the warcraft franchise goes
back
another ten and throughout that entire
period
the games have always featured one thing
prominently
war i mean come on it's literally called
warcraft and its 2012 expansion mists of
pandaria
was no exception but unlike many stories
in the series
up to that point it forced the player to
consider something
what did it really mean to live in a
world of endless expansion
and constant conflict to ask why we
fight
is to ask why the leaves fall
it is in their nature but a man by the
name of
johnny better known as double agent
wasn't having it
in a world whose map was drawn up in red
and blue
he didn't sign up for the horde or the
alliance
he chose to remain neutral
what makes a man turn neutral lust for
gold
power or were you just born with a heart
full of neutrality
but his weird approach wasn't supposed
to be an option
and while many applauded his creativity
others weren't happy that he'd chosen
this path there were a lot of people who
were just
really upset that this person decided to
spend their time doing this
so how did one zany outlook on the game
evoke such
wildly different reactions from players
and
well change world of warcraft forever
how many hours a day do you spend
leveling give me an
average like let's go through let's go
through a week a week average
i don't know if i really want to say
[Music]
leveling up as a pacifist in world of
warcraft may not be easy
but you know what is switching to geico
15 minutes could save you 15 percent or
more on car insurance
check out the link in the description
below for more information
now let's get back to the video there
are a lot of different ways to enjoy wow
especially today while content like
dungeons raids and pvp have been the
main focus of the mmo's end game
for quite some time there are a lot of
other things you can do
there are completionists and achievement
hunters
there are collectors obsessed with
obtaining mounts
pets and item appearances there's even
role playing
both serious and well
not this guy's just screaming in garage
but the famously enigmatic double agent
had a very different focus see in the
mists of pandaria expansion a new
playable race was introduced
the pandaren the race actually started
as a joke after artist
samwise dda drew something for a family
member a pandaren brewmaster named
chen stormstout was added to the bonus
campaign of warcraft
3 as a reference to the drawing so
before you go making any kung fu panda
jokes
just know that the pandaren were here
first
so the wandering isle is the starting
zone for the pandaren and it's actually
an island that's on the back of a turtle
and you play through the whole zone and
at the end of it you have to pick
neither the alliance or horde these two
warring factions
and that particular choice is kind of
thematically tied to the expansion
itself which is that
the world is being carved up into these
two pieces
people are separated by that even people
who had no affiliation with either
faction
now pretty much everyone who starts a
pandaren character leaves the island
because of course they do
that's the whole damn point now in world
of warcraft the primary
way to level up is typically to complete
quests
and as you eventually run out of them on
the isle the game directs you to
continue your adventure elsewhere
but double agent didn't think of it that
way instead
he just wanted to see if it was possible
to hit max level while remaining neutral
but since leaving the island would force
you to choose between either the horde
or alliance factions
he would need to find a way to level
while remaining there
enemies eventually stop giving xp when
you are a substantially higher level so
there was really only one option
the xp gained from gathering verbs and
mining ore
even if it's just a tiny amount so
double agent had a plan
for getting to max but that didn't mean
that there weren't
other obstacles in his way so in wow
without a faction there actually isn't a
lot you can do
the game is based around being able to
go to your capital city which
requires a faction to do things like
learn to ride a mount
sell things on the auction house so not
having that
actually meant that double agent
couldn't do a lot of things that
normal wow players could do and so in
september of 2012
double agent began his long and peaceful
journey towards the then
max level of 90. a global conflict raged
far from his island
fleets clashed and cities burned the
fates of entire nations were decided
all of it without the panda's knowledge
but despite his panda's pacifistic path
double agent was actually met with a lot
of resistance
yeah there were a lot of people who
didn't really know what to make of it
um there were rumors that he would be
forced to leave the island by a blizzard
gm
there were people who reported him as a
bot but that was just the stuff in game
like
out of game there were a lot of people
who were just really
upset that this person decided to spend
their time doing this
in the game itself double agent
completed thousands of loops through the
wandering aisle
and after about 174 days of
played time which equates to almost 4
200 hours in game
he hit max level in june of 2014
an achievement that led the community to
come out in
force to watch happen wow had its first
max level neutral character and without
intending it
double agent emerged as a kind of
celebrity
although his streams showing off his
leveling had never been particularly
lively the soft-spoken player had become
known throughout wow for his incredible
and
mind-numbing achievement which he talked
about on the pwncast podcast
so you're maxed out now on that panda do
you go back to him and if you do what
would be the purpose to sit on wandering
isle and greet the pastors by i mean
what's the purpose once you have no more
purpose
i'm pretty much sad i'll just go on and
greet people every once in a while
but i also got a neutral hunter that i'm
working on as well
he even teased the prospect of his
character leaving the island as an
elaborate april fool's joke
using the public test realm
i can't come back i don't know how it
works
anyway by the time double agent had hit
90 the next expansion was
mere months away but even with a new
level cap
he continued his grind and finally
after years of hard work his efforts
were rewarded you see for most wow
players there's something that no amount
of gold can buy
and that no world first raid boss kill
can earn you
it's the rarest of honors to be
immortalized within the game itself
for your achievements from some of the
community's most
memeable moments paul status not in the
game at all
what happened to him isn't foster dead
from no
no he survived and in fact he
was the leader of airy peak and vanilla
wow
through wrath of the lich king of course
to their
fallen heroes having your achievements
immortalized inside world of warcraft is
one of the purest forms of bragging
rights in the game
a lot of these people that that are
famous to the community for doing
certain things
are are in there that would be neat to
see something like
maybe the patient panda or the neutral
panda or something like that like that
an npc even a guy that you go and buy
some stuff from on the wandering aisle
and on july 23rd 2016 it was
double agent's turn to be honored in the
legion expansion
the wandering isle served as a class
order hall for monks
and scurrying around to urban mining
nodes
mostly in ghost wolf form was the
venerable
shaman a reference to the long gathering
grind that double agent had
used to hit max level on the island but
even being added
into the wow universe hasn't stopped
double agent from
leveling with every subsequent expansion
the only thing that's changed is that he
stopped
publicizing exactly how much time it
takes because he catches too much grief
about it
with the shadowlands expansion finally
arriving
and blizzard scaling down character max
levels to
60 the world's most famous pandaren can
resume
his quest and i'm almost tempted to say
that he can get it out of the way
quickly and actually enjoy the game's
new content
such as the dungeons outdoor areas and
everything else that's being added in
shadow lands
but that's sort of what this whole story
taught us right
there are different ways to have fun and
for double agent picking hundreds of
thousands of flowers for
years while doing a low-key stream and
maybe watching some netflix on a second
monitor
was enjoyable this is weird you
i'm never seeing your face on your
youtube channel usually there's no
there's no johnny on the youtube channel
this is a first well i usually turn the
camera on when i'm
about to hit a level at the end of the
day what double agent has done is just
basic human impulse to see a huge
impractical mountain and say i'm going
to climb
that even if there's no guarantee of a
tangible payoff
and honestly if being a peaceful
horticulture obsessed panda
is how he chooses to enjoy his journey
through wow
then who are any of us to try and stop
him
yeah i think a lot of people might say
listen i mean
what actually changed in wow as a result
of having like a max level neutral
character
and it's true that for most people like
it didn't change their day-to-day wow
experience
but i think it's important for the same
reason that
exploration is important it can teach us
something new about our environment
you know listen i'm not gonna go level a
neutral character to max level anytime
soon
but it is pretty cool that somebody
thought yeah i'm gonna do that
congrats
just don't pick in the flowers
tangible payoff tangible tangible payoff
wow wow
wow why why why
all right the best part is is for heroes
of the storm where like
you literally have like all these assets
that like blizzard
invented you know like kyle you can play
as him right and he has like a skill set
that is like
you just look at you're like oh it's
like invoker he's kind of like invoker
and i'm just in the background he's
imagining blizzard being like